[Música]
hola hola
bueno qué desafío del puesto o bien que
hablaron todo gracias por la invitación
bueno
en estos días cuando salió
la publicación del evento
me llamo gustavo para agradecerme una
cosa y recordarme parte de su historia
gustavo allá por el año 98 era una
persona de esas que ya tenía todos sus
estudios pre ocupacionales hecho para
empezar a trabajar en wall mare en aquel
momento donde se trabajaba y llamaba
insistía a todos los días la posición de
la había sido ocupada estaba esperando
una posición de cajero pero insistía
tanto le veía tantas ganas de trabajar
que le dije gustavo mira la única
posición que tengo vacante es una
posición para juntar changos no sé cómo
le llaman a casi carros o changos pero
esos estarán afuera de una empresa de
estacionamiento juntando todos los
carros que la gente deja eso fue un
miércoles el juego me junte con gustavo
y jueves ese mismo juego gustado empezó
a trabajar siguió estudiando
permanentemente desarrollando se terminó
con éxito su carrera universitaria y hoy
gustavo es el gerente de infraestructura
y sistemas de walmart así que eso es un
poco lo que le quiero contarnos de esa
historia y ese primer paso que yo
gustavo
para llegar a su objetivo para cumplir
sus planes y nunca bajar los brazos
y también quiero contarle mi historia
una una historia de una persona como que
me siento muy conforme y orgulloso por
lo que elegí me reconforta ayudar a las
personas
en las compañías y parte de esa historia
nace con esta foto de un chicle no digo
ya siempre fui muy inquieto me crié en
un barrio muy humilde mi papá obrero me
ama de casa
son mis padres o fueron mis padres
adoptivos francisco y rita me criaron
con mucho amor mis padres biológicos
fueron detenidos desaparecido en la
última dictadura un día que hay en la
casa de francisco de rita de una visita
según operativo y mis padres se fueron
no vieron nunca más y siempre fue muy
inquieto como les dije recuerdo esa
travesura que hice allá por los cuatro o
cinco años cada vez que tenía alguna
moneda salía corriendo al quiosco de
anna compraba unas golosinas y las
vendía entre mis amigos
en serio verdad un día me sobraron mis
amigos no no me quisieron comprar esas
golosinas dije qué hago con todas estas
asignaciones ayuda mi casa me las como
así que me creó un nuevo objetivo y la
fui a vender al barrio de mi tía que
estaba 4 o 5 cuadras más o menos conocía
bien el recorrido lo hacía casi a diario
con mi mamá con rita así que allí fui y
bendito a la golosina fantástico yo
venía contento con mi objetivo cumplido
de vendía toda la conocida plata en el
bolsillo para otro día poder comprar
algunas más y me encontré con el barrio
entero que me estaba buscando era de
noche fue una travesura casi me matan
pero si aprendí ahí a tener algo de auto
confianza y creo que fue un
emprendedurismo de muy chiquito viéndolo
desde ahora no desde arriba
sigamos con la segunda bueno siempre
como le decía trabajaba entrando a la
adolescencia tenía algunas profesiones
ayudaba a mi papá los fines de semana
los sábados y domingos en trabajos de
profesión en pinturas en albañilería en
algo que tenía que ver con plomería
siempre fue muy inquieto como les dije
me gustaba mantenerme esas monedas para
comprar mis chocolate mi ropa mi juguete
y francisco siempre me enseñó eso que la
cosa era con sacrificio así que estoy
muy agradecido de ese ejemplo de
francisco además de todo el amor que me
dio
entrando se acerca de los 16 17 años en
argentina no sé si acá lo hacen se van
todos una semana a pasear a algún lugar
cuando terminan el secundario se llama
viaje egresados ese viaje en bariloche
un lugar precioso que hay en la
provincia de neuquén en argentina y
obviamente ya todos los padres del
colegio donde iba habían firmado el
contrato nosotros vimos que firma no nos
queda otra ese contrato pagamos la misma
cuota y se acabó el viaje
entonces digamos que tengo acá algo
tengo que hacer para solucionar este
gran problema que tenía entonces genere
los contactos me encargue de generar una
reunión con el gerente de ventas de la
compañía llamada turismo patrick y bueno
prepare un plan prepara esa charla le
conté mi problema viste en esa charla la
verdad no puedo parar el viaje pero
también le ofrece una solución le dije
qué te parece si te ayuda a vender
viajes en colegios de la zona y bueno lo
pensaron para díaz el bombín gironda le
aceptó a la propuesta así que ahí fui
fui a bariloche y fui con mis compañeros
obviamente a cambio también un
sacrificio porque tuve que vender viajes
en otros colegios y por suerte me dio
muy buenos resultados así que bueno ahí
logré también es otra otra otra gran
experiencia que quería compartir con
ustedes hay aprende técnicas de ventas
relaciones interpersonales algunas cosas
de negociación
y dije bueno ya terminé el secundario
ahora venía una parte de la carrera
universitaria empecé a trabajar como
y empecé a trabajar como repositor en
algunas en alguna cadena de perfumerías
que tenía un conocido
y bueno ahí ahí estuve un tiempo y luego
en la carrera cuando empecé a estudiar
que tienen que creer que empecé a
estudiar las relaciones públicas ya era
como campeón mundial ya vendía tenía
relaciones interpersonales después ven
dibujos egresados también así que él
pensé que lo mío va por ese lado y un
momento me fui a este departamento de
pasantías y estudiada recursos humanos y
relaciones públicas pero siempre
pensando en relaciones públicas y
siempre con con ganas de conocer cosas
nuevas y demás y en un momento bien un
empleo que decía sam's club es una
división de vuelvan argentina dije que
es esto y ahí me metí empecé como
pasante y me quedé 12 años obviamente
tuve muy buen resultado en ventas ya
venía con algo de experiencia y tuve muy
buen resultado y la verdad que me quedé
12 año es una compañía divina la verdad
que con un grupo de gente hermosa empezó
a abrir pues abrimos un club luego y
otro y otro después vino lo súper center
que es otro negocio que tiene y wal mart
y habría uno y otro y demás y es puño en
los centros distribución logística
siempre me fue interesando entré como
pasante y me retiré como gerente
corporativo de recursos humanos y
relaciones laborales tremenda
experiencia alguien conocí bien lo que
era el mundo corporativo la vida de las
empresas pero una cosa que es muy
importante chicos el líder a las
personas para que alcancen los objetivos
eso es lo que más me gusta es el gran
desafío recuerdo allá por por los más
adelante
siempre fui así siempre fui de
despojarme de pensar que lo que está
bien hoy puede no estar también mañana
cambiar de idea eso hace muy bien ser
abierto y de acuerdo o sea cuando tenía
22 años que una de las personas que está
sentada por ahí me dijo federico dice
tengo algo que contarte luego sí que
pasó tu embarazada
tenía 22 años se venía el mundo encima a
los dos obviamente no solamente a mí
entonces qué hacemos de uno terrible
si usted se imaginarán no era una cosa
que pueda pasar obvio y bueno ahí sí ahí
nos juntamos convivimos un año seguimos
adelante aprendimos obviamente de muchas
cosas porque había que aprender a
convivir a ser parte que seamos dos lo
que es una pareja un montón de desafíos
la verdad que tremendos
y ahí fuimos adelante hoy hoy franco
tiene 21 años estoy muy orgulloso de él
me motiva todos los días con cosas que
hace
romeo que también tiene 16 2 perros se
ve lo ven a fausto de arrojo formamos
una familia hermosa así que el
aprendizaje de esta dieta es light lo
que le quiero decir es hágase cargo
obviamente lo que hacen pero siempre
vayan para adelante
hace poquito hace un mes más o menos
atrás aprendí el concepto de
inteligencia apreciativa lo venía
practicando casi toda la vida con casi
sin saberlo dirige buque bueno me parece
súper importante para compartir solos a
los chicos en esta charla
consta básicamente de cuatro elementos
bueno primero que es la aprecia tividad
alguien sabe que es la presa actividad
ese es el valor de percibir lo que nos
pasa nos pasan muchas cosas todo el
tiempo y a veces ni nos damos cuenta
donde estábamos lo que estamos haciendo
y vemos por ahí lo negativo y lo que
otras cosas no entonces esto me parece
que es fundamental para todos nosotros
para la vida personal y para la vida
laboral y tiene básicamente cuatro
elementos primero es tener la convicción
de que mis acciones importan y que a que
hago o que dijo hacer ante cada una de
las cosas que me pasan tiene impacto
esto está 'sub es súper lógico lo que le
está diciendo tiene un impacto en mí
tiene un impacto en las personas que me
rodean y obviamente también el
ecosistema al cual pertenezco cuantas
veces pensamos si hubiera dicho esto se
hubiera dicho el otro hubiera tenido
este resultado y por haber ido mejor si
dije esto o sea que sean protagonistas
de su vida participen sean protagonistas
y esto es fundamental el segundo
elemento es la perseverancia entendiendo
la perseverancia como no como algo terco
que todo piso la misma piedra
aprendiendo si perseverante y para eso
mis objetivos no importa lo que pase
todo que ir a ese objetivo un poco lo
venimos hablando en todas las charlas
otra de la tolerancia de incertidumbre
no podemos saber lo que pasará en el
futuro
obviamente no si no seríamos todos
adivinos lo que estamos en esta sala
pero si podemos trabajar para el futuro
entonces si estamos mejor preparados
seguramente los resultados sean mucho
mejores
y el último elemento es la resiliencia
saben lo que es resiliencia sí bueno
entonces y ahí me pongo como ejemplo
siempre que me caí me levanté siempre me
regenere creo que allí está el secreto
de nosotros como seres humanos ser
resiliente vamos a caernos mil veces
pero tenemos que levantarnos mil una sí
tenemos que tener mucha fuerza paralela
para llevar adelante lo que nos pasa y
yo le agrego uno que soy descendiente
italiano spoturno como dijieron
podemos hacer las cosas bien podemos
hacerla muy bien pero si ponemos pasión
seguramente hagamos excelente así que
pongamos el espacio en chicos pongámosle
mucha pasión a los a todo lo que hagamos
y van a saber que el resultado va estar
garantizado y por más
bueno y acá estamos siempre siempre me
agradecieron personas los que me
hicieron microfer y coches gracias por
ayudarme a desarrollarme gracias por
creer en mí y yo leo no no yo lo que
dice es que tú creas en ti mismo ahí
está el secreto que empiece a trabajar
el futuro que empieces a construir lo
primero que empieza a soñar lo peor es
porque pongas toda la garra para que
todos esos sueños se hagan realidad que
lo que vivimos escuchando en todas las
charlas
cuántos de ustedes saben que van a hacer
en los próximos cinco años y cinco ni
diez ni 25 saben empiecen a pensar en
eso empiecen a pensar en qué empresa
quieren trabajar qué profesión quieren
tener pongan actitud como contaron en
las otras charlas o energía pongan
entusiasmo vayan hacia adelante
de eso se trata la vida no recuerden la
historia de gustavo que juntando changos
en condiciones diría de favorables
climáticas cuando se bebe mucha agua
cuando hace calor hace un calor tremendo
tenía que ir a cada rato hidratarse
ponerse las botas el traje de lluvia
para juntar los changos y cada persona
que entretenga ese tango nuevo
obviamente nunca bajó los brazos se
capacitó permanentemente que lo que
estamos hablando seguir durante toda la
vida la capacitación permanente y hoy
hoy me llamó orgulloso de lo que logró
desde aquel momento para que para tener
la charla hoy leo se atrasa la vas a ver
si vas a ser parte de esa charla pues o
parte de esta historia y también
recuerden mi historia
empecé ayudando a mi papá con
profesiones y repositorio vendí turismo
hice muchas cosas y también soporte
muchas cosas como esta desaparición de
mis padres que le conté son cosas que
uno a veces no elige pero lo que sí
eliges cómo lo vive como lo lleva
adelante
qué pasión tiene por las cosas que tiene
por por seguir así que eso lo que les
pido a ustedes que sean abiertos al
cambio que lo que hagan lo hagan con
mucha pasión que es fundamental que
sigan esa energía que a ustedes lo guía
y para cerrar quiero decirles lo que un
poco como empecé acuérdense que por
estar hoy acá tal vez casi sin saberlo
empezaron a crear su propia historia
gracias